the actress were about to meet has just
completed a demanding role in Jacqueline
Suzanne's once is not enough she's
accompanied by an actor who proved that
once is not enough by playing a tape
several times here are the glowing
Brenda Vaccaro and the gifted Roddy
McDowall
hello hello we have two words to present
yes the first is for the best
achievement in animated short films and
the nominees are that's me
closed Mondays Will Vinton and Bob
Gardner producers the family that dwelt
apart
Evon mallet and robear darrell produces
hunger peter folds and Rene jo daung
producers forgive me say management
voyage to next faith and John Hubley
produces Winnie and the Pooh and Tigger
- hmm
here it is Wolfgang Rider Minh producer
and the winner is oh I have to say
Wolfgang's name again I'm gonna be in
trouble
the winner is closed Mondays Will Vinton
and Bob gardener
I'd like to thank family and friends and
and we'll thank you very much thanks to
members of the Academy for the
incredible honor and hello and and thank
you to all her friends back home in
Oregon
and for the Best live action short film
the nominees are rowdy climb DeWitt
Jones but you said the concert Julian
and Claude chagrin producers one-eyed
men are kings Paul Claudel and admonish
on produces Planet Ocean George V Casey
producing the violin Andrew Welch and
George pastic produces and the winner is
rowdy the winner is one-eyed men are
king haha caught on and advances
not to speak thank you for the marvelous
award we will deliver it to our star but
we don't know if he will like it because
it's a dog of 10 10 pounds and he hasn't
be able to come the customers rejected
it if thank you and thank you very much